citizens of the reject Nation I am just
walking out of Shazam 2 Fury of the Gods
IMAX invited me to an early screening
and I highly recommend you see it in
IMAX this is a big bold loud movie that
should be experienced big bold and loud
is the fury of the Gods gods are
enormous see it thusly thank you so much
to IMAX and you watching this video
please do leave a like below leave a
comment let me know what you think of
this review what you thought of the
movie let me know anything I'ma read
them let me know in the comments what's
going on also citizens of reject Nation
we the rejects are doing our first panel
on Sunday the 26th at 11 A.M at
WonderCon I am so excited to see you
there we're going to talk to the state
of DC the state of Marvel the state of
the industry and I want some fan
interactivity so we'll see you there all
right let's get into this movie now
going into this the movie has a 68
Rotten Tomatoes as of press as of the
time I'm filming this it also had a
trailer I liked in a trailer I was okay
on and the first movie is my favorite of
the DC EU so the stakes were high
impossibly high it's my favorite and
it's the sequel and then Word of Mouth
wasn't that great so I went in a little
concerned I had such a good time in this
movie I honestly think that going into
it worried helped my experience because
I smiled the entire time there is a
sense of childlike Glee and wonder that
is this Shazam universe that is so good
that I now want a rolling reboot of the
DC Universe as opposed to a hard reset
of the DC Universe I've been very clear
in that I think it's cleaner to just get
rid of the old Universe if you want a
new Superman than Henry cattle if you
want to tell these new stories that
these new characters in the roles that
they'll need to play in the DCU versus
the DC EU I like this so much I want a
rolling reboot that it seems to be what
James Gunn has described as doing and
that's that's what I want like I had
such an incredible time in this movie
the first one warms my heart in a way I
can't even describe I have such a soft
spot for foster family for blood family
versus adopted family for choosing your
own family there's a reason I love the
Fast and Furious films they're about
family yes that is also referenced in
this film and yes this film stars three
Fast and Furious folk now I am
passionately obsessed with the idea of
maintaining a child like sense of wonder
I am passionately obsessed with what it
means to be childlike without being
childish and once again they nailed that
once again they managed to make me feel
a childlike sense of wonder without the
movie being childish all the time there
are certainly childish jokes there are
moment that are just ridiculous and I
still somehow felt them and that that
brings me to some of my favorite
standout performances which would be
Jack Dylan Grazer man Jack Dylan
grazer's got his own stronghold on a
very specific type of Comedy that kid is
everywhere for a reason the kid should
be everywhere and he's so good in this
and he's so much in this and you love
him and he's the ultimate Underdog and
you're so endeared to him and he's just
such a powerful performer he he brings
you in to such a level like you want to
know him and that's that's so special
he's such a star for lack of a better
term and then Zach Levi man Zach Levi I
was so worried after the first film that
that the one note-ness of the character
could happen and it didn't the character
could be one note with a lesser actor
this could be a very cheesy in a bad way
instead the cheese Works more than not
and Zach Levi is an adorable giant kid
and it works this is big but as a
superhero and it absolutely works and it
doesn't get stale it doesn't get old the
humor lands for me nine times out of ten
they're sure are jokes that don't work
but there's so many moments that do it
outweighs them all and as I said there
were moments that emotionally didn't pay
off and I'll talk about my negatives
near the end but there are moments that
I wanted to be critical and I wanted to
more uh judgmental just as someone
watching a movie and then the Glee
outshone the cynicism I was like I
should be critiquing I didn't want to
there are some edits that I didn't love
that they took away some emotional
moments but I was still so giddy that
they never went away which also brings
me into another standout performance
diamon hansu I love that actor I'm such
a giant fan of that actor I really
wanted more of him in the first we get
more of him in this and I am so happy
with the way he's portrayed with the the
Lee of having him on screen I don't want
to give too much away but there's some
wonderful diamon hansu moments Rachel
zegler I've only seen him West Side
Story she is such a delight the thing
she's able to do in this is really
special and this is a non-spoiler review
so I don't want to give anything away
but she's able to make unbelievable
circumstances not only believable but
you care about every decision she could
make and you buy that is decision she
make even when they seem impossible she
makes the impossible possible which is
what acting is but she does it with such
Grace such dignity such Poise and you
want to love her at all times and it's
such an incredible feat what she's able
to do and in that same vein Helen Mirren
as a villain is so wonderful because she
brings a gravitas to anything she does
but here the gravitas helps serve the
entire Narrative of the film because
it's doing things that I don't think
worked in Thor dark World or other sword
and sandals superhero films because
they're gravitas to Helen mirror and you
buy a lot more the entire third act goes
into some truly absurd things and some
characters I don't want to give away
that are archetypal characters from myth
and their design is so stunning and so
wonderful and that's actually one of the
things that I think is slightly better
than the first film for me is there are
character designs that I like more than
the sins from the first film that serve
the narrative better that feel more tied
in and it gives them a comic sense of
scope this feels like a comic book in so
many ways and Shazam comics are insane
there's talking Tigers there's
crocodiles there's insane moments but
this movie is able to give you that
scope with these character designs while
also being this world of Shazam that
feels so unique to itself that also
feels like it could happen it it's
balancing definitely many tones it feels
like a comic it feels almost possible it
feels Greek myth it feels like so many
things and all of it is Glee and joy
even when the movie's dark the sense of
childlike wonder is there because of
these actors Asher Angel man one of my
only negatives I wanted more Asher and
again the emotionally resonant moments
in the first movie I do prefer the first
film I do think the first film is more
of like an A A minus it's my favorite DC
EU film this one's about a B plus for me
that's not that far off they're close
but there are some heartfelt moments in
the first film that this one didn't
quite have but I do like that the first
film was like a coming-of-age story and
this film is like a college story like
the next step in a story a good
evolution of a story but whereas the
first film felt very 80s in amblin this
one feels like the Walkabout this one
feels like pagemaster this feels like
the early 90s this feels like the late
80s going into early 90s where these
adventure movies were so unique and bold
and weird and it just goes there and it
keeps going there I do think the first
one is more for me but I do think the
second one does a lot of new things
really well and again this is something
that I enjoyed so much I want to live in
this universe more I want to dive deeper
into this world I want more of all of
these things I do think Lucy Liu I I've
Loved forever I would have liked to have
seen a little bit more of a backstory
with some of her choices I do think that
I I enjoyed the hell out of Lucy Lou but
I wanted a little bit more context for
some of her decisions I do think that
would have helped me be more invested in
that side of things but I was more
invested than I expected I went in with
very low expectations and I was rooting
actually rooting for a lot of things the
opening sequence there's an action
sequence that's on a bridge and
basically that whole sequence is kind of
a proof of concept of how to do a team
up well how to tell a family story with
dialogue and how to tell a superhero
story as a team with action and it's
balancing family and action just as the
movie does the rest of the time I love
the shazamly I have such a soft spot for
what it means to be a family as I said
at the top but the shazamilee feels like
one like those actors feel like they're
connected those foster parents feel like
their adoration for these kids
absolutely translates and then the set
piece I'm talking about is able to also
skip you ahead from where we left them
off they've just got their powers this
jumps you ahead to their working as a
team this gives you Fantastic Four X-Men
you know dynamic of of compatibility of
partnership of how they would have
learned how to use each other's Powers
with each other and then that ties into
the greater plot and Exposition it also
ties into what it means to be a family
it does the family heart and team brain
thing so beautifully well over and over
again and that opening sequence it
really just shows my love for this world
the negatives are some elements of
editing do undermine emotionality there
there are sequences where I'm like oh
they they could have used a different
take or oh you cut away as soon as it
was feeling like a moment or you could
have let that breathe believe that
bothered me there's a lot of jokes and
nine out of 10 land but when they don't
land there's a bit of a an oof to it but
that is a comedy thing like I can't
really begrudge the film that because
while that is an issue this feels more
lived in than most DC or Marvel films
when it gets to the action like a lot of
action there's always like the same
civilian or like the same people they
cut to to be like this is actually
happening this movie's got so many
moments of like civilians in Peril that
feel like people you could run into and
they're not the same person you keep
running into at the coffee shop in fact
David F Sandberg has a cameo with the
third Act of of one of these civilians
it was funny to see the director Cameo
like that I missed those but like the
movie makes you feel lived in so when
the comedy doesn't work it almost feels
like the character would find that funny
so even if it doesn't work for you it
worked for them I don't know I just I
feel like these characters are so well
fleshed out but another negative would
be that I don't I don't think they use
the young version of them enough I do
feel like there was an element of we
need Zach Levi a lot so we can't let him
be Asher and that bothered me because
Asher is a great actor and I really like
his Billy Batson but the kids overall
felt like they didn't get as much time
to balance as they did in the first film
so I would have liked to see more of the
kids would have liked some different
edits would have liked some different
moments but the score really makes the
emotional resonance work the comedy
really worked for me I was gleeful the
entire time I disagree with the Rotten
Tomatoes score and I know a lot of
people like koi likes everything he
hasn't lately and he really liked liking
something again so if this is the koi
likes everything review I'm happy it's
back I missed that koi and koi was
childlike and gleeful throughout so
thank you Shazam Lee if you love the
first one check out Shazam I hate that
it's getting underserved by the
marketing I hate that it's getting
tossed around because of the new
universe coming in and I hate that
people are like I'm not gonna see it
because it doesn't connect there are
moments that I think you'll miss out on
in cinema for this movie not being
advertised the right way and there's
also a thing that have been revealed in
marketing that are used so much more
cleverly than you think and there's an
incredible comedic set piece that is a
bait and switch tying to the first film
that is pure genius that is such a
self-aware moment from the director that
I really enjoyed the scene at dinner
I could keep going on I'm gonna do a
spoiler review hopefully with Greg uh
this weekend but for now this is going
to be my spoiler-free happy happy Shazam
fan be plus-ish loved it
foreign